this was the 25th pride march in
budapest but the event was as much about
protest
as celebration the target this man
prime minister viktor orban and his new
rules restricting the promotion of
lgbt plus rights what he calls
homosexual propaganda
he's been widely condemned and some
european politicians traveled
here to register their discontent
orbin is only on he's just starting
you know he's built a foundation that he
can stand on
um and then we're gonna start seeing
more and more rollbacks of rights and
then how can i wear a european uh mask
or flag and say
everybody's equal because that's not the
case the british embassy handed these
out declaring love is great with a
rainbow version of the union flag you
saw them everywhere
it was a march that was generally joyous
and loud
many came with children even though
bringing them here might now be
illegal so was this about putting
pressure on mr orban
can be can be a message but i don't
think so he's
care about this message unfortunately
he's not listening
no the turnout big the policing
restrained
but this raucous celebration masks a
schism in hungarian society
lgbt plus rights is a divisive issue
here
what's happening here is that people on
the pride march are having their photos
taken
with this as a backdrop that's the
counter demonstration
by those who think that the lgbt plus
community
are poisoning hungarian culture
when we spoke to them divided from the
march by metal gate
they were vociferous smaller number but
loud and belligerent
if somebody is gay i i don't
do anything but i am against the person
who is
doing gay propaganda against the
children
in the school in the kindergarten that's
what we are against not the gay person
i feel sorry for them and some of these
messages were about
driving lgbt plus people out of hungary
and the cruel irony is that these new
laws the sense of being under attack
are leading some people here to consider
abandoning their country
if i imagine myself in five or ten years
living here
and getting all this hate getting all
this negative environment
we are just very sad about them and we
are just planning to leave the country
as soon as possible
it is a year until hungary's next
general election if mr orban earns a
fourth consecutive victory
budapest pride could end up feeling very
different
adam parsons sky news budapest